this youngster was banned from
performing at his first-grade talent
show because his act was deemed too
inappropriate now as a fellow artist I
will not stand for censorship so making
his television debut please welcome Eric
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
get this girl a show on Comedy Central
now now I think we finally solved the
riddle of why hospital gowns are open in
the back pull the covers over your
wife's head I'm dreaming of a white e
tighty Christmas at least fart in them
with care I'm guessing too much
fruitcake wake up
[Music]
unfortunately we can only save your
mustache and your butthole off Lord is
dead from this day on you will simply be
known as Robbo flarty a lean mean ass
ripping machine
well not that lean take you a while to
get used to it
[Music]
oh it's an unarmed black man you're
gonna make one hell of a cop
I'll just say he was holding a knife you
have the right to remain silent but
deadly
[Music]
might want to change his name to
roboshark he didn't deserve to get
thrown under the fart bus so we brought
him out to LA to clear the air in this
week's web Redemption
[Applause]
our that is not what it looked like I
did enjoy spanking kids with a paddle I
get in your farts eat
you